esta vez aquí tenemos a la función f x y
está escrita como el producto de un
montón de expresiones de primer grado
también podemos ver esto como un
polinomio sí bueno multiplicaremos cada
uno de estos productos y escribiremos
todo esto en una forma más tradicional
pero lo que está padre aquí es que en
esta forma que estamos viendo podemos
obtener y sacar de una manera muy rápida
los ceros o las raíces del polinomio lo
cual es bastante fácil de obtener
es más déjame hacerlo recuerdan que aquí
los ceros son los valores de x que hacen
que nuestra función sea igual a 0 y
estos van a ser a dejar operando así dos
ceros o las raíces van a ser bueno x
igual a 2
x igual a menos 4 porque observa si
ponemos aquí el valor de menos 4 esto se
hace 0 y 0 por lo que sea va a ser 0 x
igual a bueno menos 5 recuerda que si
haces cualquiera de estas expresiones 0
entonces toda la función va a valer cero
porque es cero por cualquier cosa es 0 x
igual a 1 y por último x igual a
de lujo ahora como hemos dicho en varios
vídeos estos valores de x cuando los
introduces en la función obtendrás bueno
efe de 2 igual a 0 efe - 4 igual a 0
etcétera lo que significa que también
son maneras para encontrar nuestras
intersecciones con el eje x a qué me
refiero bueno para eso que te parece si
me dejas dibujar por aquí unos ejes voy
a dibujar un gran eje y bueno por acá
tengo que mi valor más grande es 9 y mi
valor más pequeño es menos 5 así que voy
a poner por aquí más o menos me van a
quedar así déjame poner que estos son
mis ejes que estos son mis ejes por aquí
tengo al eje james y por aquí tengo al
eje x y bueno en el eje x vamos desde 1
3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 y bueno en el eje x para atrás
voy a poner menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 ok
entonces ahora vamos a graficar esto
cuando x vale 2
ya sabemos que f 2 es cero si pones 2 en
esta expresión bueno esto x s 0 y 0 por
lo que sea es 0 entonces déjame ponerlo
con este color cuando xv al de 2
efe de 2 toma el valor de 0 y eso quiere
decir que también el punto 20 estará en
la gráfica de gem igual a fx entonces el
punto 2 120
en este punto de aquí va a estar en la
gráfica que buscamos no está si pones x
igualados la expresión
toda esta expresión se hace igual a 0 y
también el punto 0 2 está coordenada que
tenemos aquí define
una de nuestras intersecciones con el
eje x bien hagamos nosotros cuando x
vale menos 4 también me pasa lo mismo
menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 aquí tengo otra
intersección con el eje x déjame usar el
color rosa aquí tengo este de aquí
cuando x vale menos 5 así que lo voy a
poner por aquí cuando x vale menos 5
también voy a utilizar este color este
color verde cuando x vale 1 cuando x
vale 1 y por último voy a usar este
color morado cuando x vale 9 123456789
de lujo aquí está otra intersección con
el eje x
ahora no voy a dibujar completamente la
gráfica de esta función
efe de x pero lo que sí quiero dejar muy
claro es que estos puntos donde hay una
intersección con el eje x son los únicos
puntos donde hay intersecciones con el
eje x es decir los ceros de mi función
los ceros reales y es que ellos definen
todos los puntos donde voy a tener una
intersección en el eje x ya que piénsalo
si existiera un punto de intersección en
el eje x que no fuera un cero
bueno pues tendría que ser un cero no
hay de otra ya que la función en ese
punto tomaría el valor de cero entonces
ahora lo que quiero ver es si la función
se va a mantener positiva o negativa
entre dos puntos que son ceros es decir
si estamos arriba del eje x o abajo del
eje x vamos a probarlo y para eso qué te
parece si nos fijamos en
un valor que esté entre menos 4 y 1 y ya
que lo elija
vamos a ver si la función va a ser
positiva o negativa en ese punto y bueno
un valor fácil de tomar se me ocurre es
efe de cero así que vamos a pensar qué
es lo que pasa en mi función solamente
en los signos cuando x vale 0 déjame
ponerlo así cuando x vale 0
efe de 0 que si nos tendría bueno
pensemos en lo siguiente solamente me
voy a aplicar en los signos entonces
0 - 2 en esta primera parte tendría un
signo negativo y después me quedaría 0 4
lo cual me daría un signo positivo muy
bien y después tendría 0 + 5 lo cual me
daría un signo positivo y después tengo
cero menos 1 lo cual me da un signo
negativo y por último tengo cero menos 9
en lo cual también me va a dar un signo
negativo entonces podemos ver que cuando
x vale 0
vamos a obtener veamos estos dos son un
signo negativo estos dos también son un
signo negativo y negativo por negativo
me va a dar algo positivo pero después
voy a multiplicar por algo negativo por
lo tanto efe de cero no sé qué valor
tendrá pero va a tener un valor negativo
de eso estamos seguros entonces la
función va a tomar un valor negativo no
sé cuál en ese punto pero no sólo eso
sabemos que va a tener ese valor
negativo en todo este intervalo ya que
por si alguna razón tomáramos un valor
positivo y como sabemos que la función
es una función continua entonces
tendríamos que cruzar el eje x y
tendremos que cruzar el eje x en otro
valor que sería un cero pero como ya
sabemos que en este intervalo no hay
ceros entonces la función no puede tomar
ningún valor positivo en este intervalo
entonces no sé cómo se ve la función
y todos sus valores van a ser negativos
se va a ver más o menos algo así la
función se va a mantener negativa entre
estos dos valores ahora pensemos en
nuestro siguiente intervalo en este
pequeño intervalo que tengo aquí y bueno
estoy casi seguro que va a cambiar de
signo pero vamos a verificarlo y para
eso vamos a ver no sé un punto entre
menos 5 y menos 4 se me ocurre menos 4.5
entonces lo voy a poner aquí
efe de menos 4.5 bueno vamos a fijarnos
de nuevo en los signos y qué signos
tengo veamos aquí primero tengo menos
4.5 2 bueno eso es algo negativo y
después tengo menos 4.54 ok eso es
negativo también y después tenemos menos
4.55 eso va a ser positivo positivo y
después tengo aquí algo negativo
y por último tengo por acá algo negativo
muy bien y como en este caso tenemos un
número par de signos negativos entonces
el valor que va a tomar la función en
menos 4.5 va a ser algo positivo
entonces podemos decir que en este
intervalo vamos a tomar valores
positivos se va a ver más o menos así y
luego es muy probable que en el
siguiente intervalo cambiemos de nuevo a
un valor negativo entonces la gráfica se
va a invertir a negativa inclusive lo
podemos probar no sé se me ocurre que
tomamos un valor muy negativo por
ejemplo
efe de menos 10 bueno pues fm 10 que si
no tendrá lo podemos ver aquí menos 10
menos 2 eso va a ser negativo y después
tengo menos 10 más 4 sigue siendo
negativo y después menos 10 más 5 sigue
siendo negativo y después tengo negativo
y negativo
y negativo lo cual nos va a dar un valor
negativo ojalá y veas con mayor claridad
a dónde va todo esto y por ejemplo aquí
va a ser muy probable que tengamos signo
positivo algo más o menos así y bueno
podemos asegurar que entre 2 y 9
regresemos a valores negativos algo más
o menos así y bueno realmente estoy
inventando las alturas de esta función
podría ser que de 1 a 2 tengamos una
función que tenga una altura mayor y
después bajen algo más o menos así y que
tal vez entre 2 y 9 baje mucho mucho
mucho mucho y después vuelva a subir
algo más o menos así no sé realmente
estoy inventando de nuevo la gráfica no
forzosamente se va a ver exactamente así
pero lo importante aquí son los cambios
de signo y por lo tanto después del 9
podemos ver que esta gráfica va a tomar
valores positivos
podemos comprobarlo vamos a verificarlo
pensando en un valor muy positivo se me
ocurre efe de 10 déjame hacerlo con otro
color vamos a pensar en f de 10 f de 10
va a tener un signo bueno va a ser
positivo positivo y después tengo
positivo y después tengo positivo y
después tengo 10 menos 1 es positivo y
por último 10 menos 9 es lo cual también
es positivo y entonces podemos ver que
10 va a tomar un valor positivo en
nuestra función realmente no sé cuál sea
su valor pero podemos asegurar que va a
ser positivo pero lo importante que hay
que ver aquí son dos cosas en primer
lugar que los ceros son los únicos
lugares en donde tenemos intersecciones
con el eje x y la otra cosa es que entre
esos ceros si nos tomamos un punto y
éste tiene un valor negativo entonces
todo el intervalo va a tener un valor
negativo y si nos tomamos un punto y ese
punto tiene un valor positivo entonces
todo ese intervalo va a tomar un valor
positivo y bueno claro al final de ese
intervalo nos vamos a encontrar con dos
ceros entonces por ejemplo si alguien te
dijera cuál es el signo de f el signo
d
en el intervalo
el intervalo menos 4 menor que x menor
que 1 que de hecho fue en el intervalo
en el que empezamos este de aquí
entonces dirás bueno efe siempre es
negativa en ese intervalo si no
incluiría es claro los puntos extremos y
bueno no incluimos esos puntos los
puntos extremos de los puntos finales
porque no tenemos un menor o igual aquí
entonces no los estamos incluyendo 10
por eso que puedes decir que esta
función en este intervalo siempre va a
ser negativa ahora en cuidado porque si
alguien te diera un intervalo distinto
si te dijera por ejemplo en este
intervalo en el intervalo 19 se me
ocurre en el intervalo 19 que valdo les
va a tomar mi función y bueno aquí hay
que tener cuidado porque estamos pasando
por otro 0 lo que quiere decir que en
este intervalo mi función tomaría
valores positivos o 0 o negativos ojo la
clave aquí
que entre dos raíces sin incluirlas y
sabes el valor que toma un punto entre
esas dos raíces ya sea negativo o
positivo entonces la función siempre
será positiva o negativa en todo ese
intervalo va a ser el signo a lo largo
de ese intervalo sin incluir claro los
puntos extremos